previously on the walking dead get the
gates open
we've got wounded I want to know why you
thought bringing more mouths to feed was
a good idea words getting out that you
want to leave the motor in well here
isn't doing us any good you should think
about coming with us
you and Clem no one's trying to cut you
out of anything
those look like did you tell anyone out
there who you were or that you were tied
to this place that's right I know who
you are and I know you're a killer he's
not dead
somebody help me come on we know this
guy's not gonna make it sounds like a
car a shitload of food and supplies back
here you're right we shouldn't take this
the rest of us are taking this stuff
don't worry little girl and it's got
their eye on that dairy as long as they
keep getting food from them you'll be
safe
hey how'd the gun breath my name's Bob
welcome to episode three of walking dead
we know that jack is a [ __ ] when a band
is in the front and the zombie can fly
all right so I replayed everything again
because forever isn't Midas's decisions
don't go through each episodes this game
series adapts to the choices you make
the story's tailored I knew this
yeah I wonder if it's gonna start epic
like the other ones its blur this time
around breasts other one was Gemma and
the first one was right man I'm thinking
about National Guard orders a vacation
I'll say huh nice backpack Kenny alright
what are we doing
oh I remember we're gonna look for food
yeah episode three long road I hey nice
back package like this is our lucky day
why cuz there's no zambese triple dot
well let's just get to it dinner
anything and leaves you have new clothes
now you look better in that shirt
actually I didn't like his jacket
not that it's important Oh Tim and tools
and more not that star it's the best
oh yeah he got shot me where do you come
down on staying or going
you mean packing up the motel and
getting in the RV yeah we've been
talking about it but you made up your
mind yet I think we should go we should
go
motels run its course it's not safe
you're damn right it has we pile into
the RV and don't pull over till we see
water and if Lily's dead cell and
staying then well that's the way it goes
yeah it's you and me my man
I got a helicopter crash neighbor it's
prescription I guess it really wanted
them prescription oh that's where we
were hiding just like last time over the
rig into the pharmacy and scraped
together whatever supplies are left
wouldn't be much in there hey we're out
of options
somethings better than nothing good
point Kenny and just don't like this can
I go first
ah look 1k the ladders come loose I'm
not sure how many more trips she's got
in her I'm not sure how many more trips
we've gotten us one no kidding huh well
you have an epic mustache I got anything
all right this is not gonna work
let's click on it anyway it's freaking
high I don't think it's gonna be that oh
that's not gonna work
looks like she's had it what now I'll
find another way
I don't like dads move on I don't like
this at all maybe we can find a rope or
something that's a bow oh hello
what is this Lilly's not doing so good
huh well when did kill her dad you know
her dad we did kill her dad we didn't
kill her dad
come on today you gotta go faster the
night
what if the zambese can then what are
you gonna do are you gonna move the
entire thing
can't you just climb you crazy Li he's
not my idea I'm not for this how do you
know it we didn't have a check for gas
Wow hmm barrel I got my eye on you
yellow Hummer Oh God this is not gonna
work
oh never mind
oh it has weighed thin it's totally gone
away your girls still upset with me for
taking stuff out of that car last week
your girl who's my girl is it climbing I
would've let a new trick Christ I've
heard European what's done is done
did you mean Carly
now I duck was asking about that guy at
Hershel's farm last night well it's a
lie that wasn't true it fazed him yeah I
mean we're sounds pretty stupid well
okay now that Herschel Sun is one of how
many now we've all seen a lot worse why
I'm a tough kid you know no like I said
not much faces him but it's starting to
add up
farm dairy ah to the coast get him out
of all this madness all right just help
me out
Jason cries I don't give me sad about
you yeah sure you up for this
Leah I'm fine I've got this give me your
hand all right geez ah
Jace's Christ Kelly we could have been
oh you elected the zambese are you okay
man sirs you okay I'm fine
[ __ ] I'm sorry pal I thought he'd be
healed up better lucky it wasn't any
worse you could oh no what oh [ __ ]
stop screaming what the hell is that
what I say no don't shoot before you get
up I can get labor tour we gotta do
something we can't see she stays alive
yeah fine
I gotta make a decision here don't I
well okay what is she doing now I'm
sorry that I was trying to strike the
Sammy loverboy back and now we made it
up you're like one second
I tried I don't look at me like I try I
really tried sitting you should be good
to clear this place out but we ain't got
all day
get everything you can out of these
racks don't forget underneath the
counter this time I'll clear down here
and then we got a go all right well we
got a medicine box and we got supply see
more supplies energy buy medicine
butcher does medicine butter
it's a place corn flakes all right let's
check over here man
Madison she's gone there's not much time
now all right medicine box under the
counter any to buy energy by slapping a
pull-up bar
clapper xalapa 12 items come on pills
you can do better than this but hey
kenick IRA all right fine
left left like let's get all this fast
all right get your mom's job everyone
have a lot of time clicking like a boss
I think that's everything
Oh bikini holy [ __ ] it doesn't do
anything it has to do it I think help me
get it never guess
oh [ __ ] don't shoot yet French and y'all
fight holy [ __ ] they're so fast
what
oh [ __ ] lay round come on that escalated
quickly god damn it's like they have
teleporting Jim kept a bit whoa the
bandits are after them huh
well making ways IRA that they won that
problem
sup clinic he's playing with that
walkie-talkie
a girl then found some stickers in a
drawer and I put him on my walkie it's
neat
I'll find you that man sweet speedy
color what's going on here looks like we
got the kid on watch again would you get
might as well leave a sign out that says
the men are gonna come and rape our
women and children
huh Adam get it whatever so what did you
get begad
lonnis nah we're fine by the way
nice work this will keep us going if we
carry on like this we'll get through the
winter here the winter will freeze our
asses off here is piling into an RV with
you two after what you did to my dad is
so appealing why wouldn't it be you know
I'll do what it takes to keep everyone
safe
we're already safe take a look at the
wall Lily that's not graffiti those are
bullet holes and we got enough arrow
shafts sticking out of it to dry our
laundry and that's all beside the fact
that Macon is busting at the seams with
Walker's we had to go eventually we
don't have to do anything you didn't
want to go because of your dad's health
but he's gone now
hey don't dunk you can't pee in the
bullet I had it again are we can it
Carly sup girl don't boss people around
I'm sorry somebody needs to make
executive decisions for the group though
we're stronger together you're capable
and he was strongest together it can't
be you versus us Lily we're sorry for
what happened to your dad but we're in
this together now Haley a weird
situation
what about protection what about when
this place Falls somebody's got to be
thinking about this [ __ ] how has this
not been working we have everything we
need to me Lily let's be as Kenny and
you what about Medicine triple dot
triple doc you know how we got these
supplies we got lucky and let a girl get
eaten out there what some girl came
screaming out of an alley
she had dead hanging all over her she
gave us enough time to get everything we
could out of the drugstore and you just
let her suffer like what well it was a
mistake I tried it I really tried like I
mean it was a mistake we got our
supplies but we should have tried to
save her put her out of her misery well
some options were off the table
son of a basically thanking Lee for not
shooting that girl I do it's not so easy
for him Oh Carly then like makin and
it's people aren't savable it's not a
town it's full of walkers and the people
who were left are dying and wandering
out onto the streets it's hell
on earth and it's coming this way going
to be easier out on the road how would
you know what I know I know you're not
above murder I know somebody has been
stealing our supplies that's right
stealing and I know the list of people I
could trust your gets smaller every day
change this guy's welcome everybody get
out
she wants to masturbate we need to make
a decisions
all right triple dot I'm sorry it says I
know what to say that I'm waiting none
of this is getting any easier
mmm a triple a lot the [ __ ] out of that
what is that
don't triple dot me you don't trip
allowed me back come into a head
you can say that I girl let's go in him
out of the room well I think you did
good today man I find myself thinking
that most days mm-hmm I know what you
mean drugs probably worth following up
with Lily about what she was saying
about missing supplies mmm you like to
hurt wound up the way she is I don't
want to see her paranoid no question
mm-hmm and I'd like to talk when you've
got a minute oh I know what she mean
we're talking not so much talking all
right
Oh hmm all right he's gonna get some
leaves gonna get some please like I
gotta get laid yeah whoo oh [ __ ] I gotta
check on clammy but I'm gonna get laid
I'm gonna get some I'm gonna get some
I'm gonna get some all right lemme
you'll be safe all right
Poppa pig got some business taking care
so what that's it you're working on Clem
it's called a leaf rubbing my teacher
Miss Moore showed us how to do them when
we went to the Botanical Garden once
that's pretty cool I used to do that too
can I see you claiming it's the same Oh
God kind of really something I'll make
one for you too ah all right like it
here
he don't like it here do you want to
leave
where are we going somewhere else I
don't know maybe if I knew where all
right honey
it'd be a good thing to know I'll talk
to you later clean okay Dora all right
let's get some Breaking Bad oh that face
is not good talk to Lily yet no not yet
I will
what I wanted to say was I've been
thinking a lot about you ah I think
about you to think about you too
[Music]
our group is small you're small
you're a convicted killer Carly Jonathas
do you think people should know yes they
deserve to and not because you're a bad
man I think the opposite of those two
things
people need to know because we're
hanging by a thread here and I can't see
Lily talk about you without thinking
it's the next thing she's going to say
you don't have to tell everyone but
think about who you trust and take the
opportunity while you have it she has a
point can we
you're probably right of course I'm
probably right YG's what might be pissed
and telling them might cause some
trouble but it will be a far cry from
what will happen if they don't hear it
from you yeah
so right then yeah I'll do it but people
in there you're totally ready good I
think it's for the best
can we go now No
there we go that's a little prettier
don't call me small
she's totally flat degwin thing is there
anything else you want to talk about
think people are ready to hear about me
do you feel safe here have you thought
about Lily you know you feel safe here I
guess I gotta show my concern with a
heated floor and a high-rise apartment
and hand me a full-bodied Malbec and
then I'll feel safe I don't know that
this place is fine but we all know that
that could change at any second
all right look into this thing good idea
I got to talk to clay me first
not climate you need to know have some
secrets clammy I need to talk to you for
a second straight up clam okey okey
dokey well I was addressing with a man
that was in a car accident
I remember your leg was bleeding no I
was in was a police car and I was on my
way to jail for committing a crime I
need to tell you now because I don't
want you to hear it any other way
okay ya have anything to say I don't
think so you can go home back to your
things that was easy alright she
understands that's good let's talk to
Kenny now Kenny I don't know how to say
this
hey you two but there's some really ugly
we're okay just having a little spat
spat don't carry guns now and I don't
like it it's the way it's gotta be
I know but I'm not getting used to it
well then get your yeah how are you Lee
I gotta tell you something I don't want
to talk to Katya
god damn Kenny you got a second I need
to tell you something oh sure pal well
you got this better get me laid it's
serious oh no what the she-devil do to
you setup man shut up
all right give them money I was on my
way to prison three months ago mm-hmm no
[ __ ]
little [ __ ] it wasn't for touching kids
was it man what I got a ass no I killed
a guy in a fight uh-huh hmm must have
been a real piece of [ __ ] if you had to
haul off and kill him so we're straight
there Lee look at everything this mess
has got us doing now I'm sorry you went
through whatever you went through yeah
we're straight all right
so far so good I guess we gotta tell
Lily all right there goes nothing
early love a I might am i interrupting
something are you done masturbating I'm
sorry
it's like you don't have to apologize
did you come in here to give me hell or
to coddle me I don't know what this mean
I'm following up about said triple dot
look I know those things me and I need
your help there's a reader somebody one
of us out there he or she or they have
been taking things
I don't really give a [ __ ] all right
trip a lot so you don't believe me
look different every trip antibiotics
oxy [ __ ] anything with opium in it well
there was someone in it's fine
I keep my own that ones getting messed
with I'm a [ __ ] mess right now but
I'm not stupid
I know what happens if I start a witch
hunt so you want me to start one I want
you to poke around no hell no no sir
what's there to go on I found this
tossed into the garbage hmm we don't
toss out equipment we fix it you'd only
try to get rid of a flashlight if you're
using it when you shouldn't
ah seems like you manufacturing this
from nothing who'd me wrong I'll just
assume it was you oh but I was gonna
tell her God an jury it's probably doc
Jesus doc God I'm sorry I heard you guys
talking it was you wasn't it you Lou all
[ __ ] can I help doc could stay out of my
way your inner grace detective and I can
be Dick Grayson you're a dick all right
that's Robin I know who it is and don't
try to lecture me all right find you
Robin but I'm back nice you're Robin I'm
mother [ __ ] Batman if you do that
again I'll kill you
I don't know go look around let me know
if you find anything weird I'm on the
case god damn you doc okay [ __ ] I want
to kill him what is this so this is
really all that's happening right now
it's kind of dull isn't it all right
let's ice-climbing about it hey
Clementine Hayley you didn't
accidentally break a flashlight did you
no did duck see I did no I did
duck break the flashlight I don't think
so he's just always blaming me for stuff
out of a baby bug on his pill
did you do that yes
nice going Clemmy ha that's why I love
you cleany
nice going alright I bet it was this
fatty gotcha
do you guys know anything about a broken
flashlight
[ __ ] we don't got many of those yeah
it's a problem the glass and the bulb
are all busted out I saw some broken
glass over by the ice machine I meant to
clean it up before the kids hurt
themselves on it
I forgot though alright Sherlock pills
continues I guess we got to end it here
they always gotta introduce any of
things and [ __ ] like that so I'm sorry
that not that much happened well there
were dozens they'd be killing anyway sky
come to earth today and I'll see an
exhibit soda whatever I think happy
breath kidding I tell you that I've got
it don't worry about it
I know what I'm doing I'm an axe but how
the hell did I do that get down
what nice I love the whopper
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] move my entire deck